wie geht es jetzt weiter mit nordkorea
sprechen wir darüber mit einem mann der
im weitesten sinne in asien aufgewachsen
ist nämlich nämlich in der ddr mit olaf
schubert und damen und herren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der heute show ja urlaub schön dass du
da bist pulverfass nordkorea wie
bereitest du dich auf das
unaussprechliche auf den ernstfall vor
vorbereiten auf dem atomkrieg dass ich
also ich bin da eher so dass spontanen
typ sagt ich lasse es kommen und dann
mal sehen wie es auf mich wirkt also 1
war atomwaffen einsatz das ist immer
unangenehm
besonders nach 18 uhr also nicht nur der
lärm ist ja auch der track das ist also
ich habe also ich leide ja unter ganz
schwerer wasserstoffbomben intoleranz
also mir ist es sowieso irgendwie alles
zum modernen also ich stehe er so auf
die konventionellen waffen noch so wie
früher laserschwert und so also oder auf
die fresse verbucht trump oder kim jong
un wo liegen bei dem duell deine
sympathien für wen bist du meine
sympathien
die habe ich für menschen die offen und
ehrlich sagen das weiß ich hand die
hinterseer oder mein hamster oder
irgendwie sei aber rein von der vernunft
ändere ich dann doch schon eher zu kenia
ist noch sehr jung und ich sehe in ihm
das verwundete kind da ist diese nicht
zerstörte aber verletzte seele sage ich
mal
also es ist sein vater war schon
diktator sein großvater war auch
diktator beide waren gleichzeitig auch
seine mutter und in sein leben fehlt was
weibliches na ja er hatte mal eine
freundin aber die hatte dann irgendwie
unglücklich vor die kanone gebunden
jetzt sind die anderen kandidatinnen
auch irgendwie gehemmt also
es schaue dann einfach ja er hat wohl
längste alle menschen die hier gelebt
hatte umgebracht und er ist isoliert im
eigenen land erste 1 gegen übergewicht
und ich glaube diese bombe ist ja
irgendwie auch nur ein schrei nach liebe
da habe ich ein jahr da sind sie dass er
dumm halten anruft und sagt du ich mag
dich ja es wäre eher am anfang ja so was
ähnliches muss wahrscheinlich passiert
sollte hat aber auf der anderen seite
nicht vielleicht tramp doch meine zeit
lang das handy wegnehmen und könnte es
wirklich sein dass der nächste weltkrieg
durch twitter ausgelöst wird also ich
meine ja es wäre zumindest mal gut wenn
in weltkriege jetzt nicht wieder von den
deutschen ausgelöst wird ich finde die
welt kennt es nicht darauf ausruhen dass
wir diesen service ständig anbieten und
es ist vielleicht irgendwie auch die
neue zeit sage ich mal dass der krieg
eben per twitter beginnt ja dann geht so
eine gute liste rom kann sich jeder
eintragen der macht
das klingt erst mal unglaublich aber ich
meine beziehung werden ja auch per sms
beendet ja das ist für mich auch
unglaublich aber trotzdem ist wird
praktiziert das jetzt nicht von mir klar
also ich habe noch nie so eine frau
adieu gesagt ja sms also ja ich habe
noch ein fax geschrieben ohne schuhe und
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]